>> Greg: HOW CAN THEY CLAIM
THERE WAS NO VACCINATION WHEN
BIDEN HAD HIS PREINAUGURATION?
BIDEN MAKES OF FACTS ABOUT WHEN
HE GOT VAXXED.
THE WHITE HOUSE TWEETED "WHEN
PRESIDENT BIDEN TOOK OFFICE,
MILLIONS WERE UNEMPLOYED AND
THERE WAS NO VACCINE AVAILABLE."
BUT AS EVEN THE MOST CASUAL
POLITICAL OBSERVER WOULD NOTE,
BIDEN TOOK OFFICE JANUARY 20,
2021, AT LEAST A MONTH AFTER HE
TOOK THE COVID VACCINE.
HE MADE A BIG DEAL OUT OF IT.
A MONTH EARLIER HE TWEETED
"TODAY I RECEIVED THE COVID-19
VACCINE."
JANUARY 13, A WEEK BEFORE HE
TOOK OFFICE, THE SAME TWITTER
WHITE HOUSE TWITTER ACCOUNT
POSTED THIS VIDEO WITH THE
CAPTION "PRESIDENT-ELECT BIDEN
RECEIVED HIS SECOND DOSE OF THE
COVID-19 VACCINE."
IT APPEARS THEY ARE NOT EVEN
TRYING TO HIDE THE FACT THAT
THEY'RE LYING.
JOE'S ATTEMPT IS NEAR
DONALD TRUMP TOTALLY BACKFIRED.
HE CALLED TRUMP THE GREAT MAGA
KING.
MY REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES SAY
THEY HELP THE WORKING-CLASS AND
MIDDLE-CLASS PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE INFLATION.
THEY ARE DEAD WRONG.
UNDER MY PREDECESSOR, THE GREAT
MAGA KING, THE DEFICIT INCREASED
EVERY SINGLE YEAR.
>> Greg: IT LOOKS LIKE HE IS
ABOUT TO BELT OUT A SINATRA HIT.
ALSO WHAT HE JUST SAID DOESN'T
EVEN MAKE SENSE.
HE SLAMMED TWO DISCONNECTED
SENTENCES TOGETHER AND GIVES
TRUMP A POSITIVE NICKNAME.
IT'S ALWAYS A SICK BURN TO CALL
YOUR ENEMY A KING.
WHICH THEN TRUMP NATURALLY
EMBRACED, POSTING THIS
"LORD OF THE RINGS" STYLE MAGA
MEME ON HIS OWN SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORM.
HE LOOKS GOOD AS A BRUNETTE.
IT'S A SAD, GRIM WEEK FOR OLD
JOE.
WHAT HAS JOE GOT TO SAY?
>> NO, NO, NO IT WAS A GOOD
WEEK, A GOOD WEEK.
I CAME UP WITH NICKNAMES THIS
WEEK ALL BY MYSELF.
I DIDN'T HAVE ANY HELP FOR MANY
PEOPLE.
IT WAS ME.
ULTRA MAGA, THAT WAS MINE.
ONE DAY LATER I CAME UP WITH THE
MAGA KING.
I AM DOING IT.
I AM PLAYING THE NAME GAME.
ME MY MO MAGA.
I'LL DO ANOTHER ONE.
I'LL DO IT TOMORROW.
>> Greg: CARLEY, HOW DUMB IS
HE?
>> Carley: WHAT'S REALLY
HAPPENING IS THAT BIDEN IS
TRYING TO COPY TRUMP.
YOU CAN'T BE DOING THAT.
TRUMP WAS A MASTER CLASS IN
CHILDISH AND HILARIOUS AND
EFFECTIVE INSULTS.
LITTLE MARCO, LYING TED, CRICKET
HILLARY, SLEEPY JOE.
WE STILL REMEMBER.
THEY ACTUALLY AFFECTED THEIR
POLITICAL CAREERS.
BIDEN DOESN'T, YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> Greg: LOW ENERGY JOB.
THAT KILLED HIM.
HE GAVE DONALD TRUMP A
COMPLEMENT.
I WAS TALKING TO LARA TRUMP.
THANK YOU FOR MAKING ME A MEMBER
OF THE ROYAL FAMILY.
>> Greg: FINALLY A REAL ROYAL
FAMILY.
NOT LIKE THESE CRAZY PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA.
TYRUS, THAT TWEET ABOUT THE
VACCINATION STUFF I THINK THE
MEDIA IS FINALLY FEELING LIKE
THE WHITE HOUSE IS JUST
INSULTING THEM.
THEY ASSUME THE MEDIA IS NOT
GOING TO FACT-CHECK HIM THEY ARE
GOING OKAY, WE SAW HIM GET THE
VACCINE.
>> Tyrus: IT MIGHT NOT BE THE
MEDIA.
I THINK ITS PEOPLE.
EVERYONE WHO IS LIKE, WHAT?
WAS IT PUTIN'S FAULT WE DIDN'T
HAVE THE VACCINE?
ALL THIS ADMINISTRATION DOES IS
POINT FINGERS.
ANYONE CAN DO THAT.
EVEN IF YOU DON'T HAVE FINGERS,
YOU CAN GO LIKE THAT.
IT'S NOT A HARD THING TO BLAME.
EVERY 3-YEAR-OLD I'VE EVER COME
ACROSS IS PHENOMENAL AND BLAMING
SOMEBODY ELSE FOR SOMETHING THEY
DID, EVEN LITTERING NEITHER
FILLED DIAPER.
THEY WILL BE LIKE, DADDY DATED.
THAT'S WHAT OUR ADMINISTRATION
DOES.
THEY HAVE NO SOLUTIONS.
EVERY TIME THEY POINT SOMETHING
OUT AND LIE ABOUT SOMETHING,
THEY HAVE TO DOUBLE DOWN.
THE WOKE PROGRESSIVE THING.
IF YOU PROVE IT'S A LIE, THEY
STRETCH IT AND KEEP IT GOING.
LIKE TO -- THE THING WITH TRUMP
AND THE BANKS.
EVERY TIME YOU LOOK AT POLLING
AND EVERY TIME YOU HEAR AMERICAN
PEOPLE TALK, NO ONE IS FALLING
FOR IT.
THERE IS NO CURTAIN.
THEY HAVE NO BRAVADO AND THEY
ARE NO GOOD AT INSULTS.
I'VE NEVER IN MY LIFE BEEN LIKE
LOOK, GUTFELD.
LET ME THINK.
LOOK, KING OF THE LITTLE PEOPLE.
>> Greg: THAT SOUNDS GOOD.
>> Tyrus: EVEN THOUGH HE IS
PHYSICALLY UNDERACHIEVING, STILL
THE HIGHEST IN THE CLASS.
DOESN'T REALLY WORK.
>> Greg: DO YOU HAVE A
NICKNAME?
>> Kat: NONE THAT I CAN SHARE
HERE.
>> Greg: OH, MY GOD.
WOULD YOU LIKE A NICKNAME?
HAVE YOU THOUGHT OF ANY
NICKNAMES FOR YOURSELF?
>> Kat: NONE THAT I CAN SHARE
HERE.
>> Greg: ISN'T IT INTERESTING
THAT THE GUY THAT CLAIMED -- HE
WANTED A RETURN TO NORMALCY,
WANTED TO UNIFY THE COUNTRY HAS
DONE NEITHER.
HE'S ALMOST CREATED SOCIETAL
UPHEAVAL.
I FEEL TERRIBLE ABOUT YOUR
CHILDREN NOT HAVING BABY
FORMULA.
>> Kat: I FEEL SO TERRIBLE I
HAVE NEVER MET THEM.
>> Tyrus: YOU WORK TOO MUCH.
>> Kat: I DO.
>> Greg: SO NICE OF YOU TO
LEAVE THEM IN THE FOREST.
THEY ARE VERY OUTDOORSY.
>> Greg: THEY MAKE SO MANY
FRIENDS.
>> Kat: THE WOLVES ARE DOING A
GREAT JOB.
>> Greg: THEY RAISE A LOT OF
KIDS, THOSE WOLVES.
>> Kat: BIDEN JUST KEEPS
TALKING.
FOR A COUPLE YEARS I WAS DATING
THIS HORRIBLE HORRIBLE MATH,
ACTUAL SOCIOPATH.
HORRIBLE MONSTER.
I STARTED SEEING THIS OTHER GUY
WHO WAS STUPID.
EVERYTHING THAT HE SAID MADE ME
REPULSED AND DISGUSTED BUT I
KEPT HIM AROUND.
I WAS LIKE, HE IS NICE TO ME.
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE VOTED FOR
BIDEN JUST BECAUSE HE WASN'T
TRUMP.
YOU CAN ONLY BE THE REBOUND GUY
FOR SO LONG BEFORE YOU HAVE TO
OFFER SOMETHING ELSE OR PEOPLE
WILL BE OVER IT.
>> Greg: GRADE POINT.
>> Kat: THANK YOU.
I AM FULL OF THEM.
>> Greg: GRADE POINT KAT, THAT
WILL BE YOUR NICKNAME.
GP K.
GP K KILLER.
>> Kat: THERE WE GO.
EXCEPT, LAST WORD TO YOU.
>> THE GREAT MEGA KING?
>> Pete: THAT MAKES HIM DONALD
THE GREAT, LIKE ALEXANDER THE
GREAT, ALFRED THE GREAT.
>> Greg: HOW DO YOU THINK THEY
GOT THOSE NAMES?
IVAN THE TERRIBLE.
HE LOVED THAT NAME.
>> Pete: HE MADE TORTURE GREAT
AGAIN.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
YOU REALLY THINK IVAN WAS
TERRIBLE?
OR WAS HE JUST MISUNDERSTOOD?
>> Tyrus: HE DISEMBOWELED
EVERYBODY.
>> Kat: I'M GOING TO GO ON THE
RECORD.
>> Greg: WHAT IF IT WAS JUST
IVAN THE DISAGREEABLE?
IVAN THE SLIGHTLY MIFFED.
I GO WITH -- WE GO WITH IVAN THE
TERRIBLE.
I GUESS WE BEAT THI